uh my boys at suplex i think it's at
suplex sneakers on instagram
i went to them because they're they're
my shoe plug right i have all the shoes
in the world so they're my shoe plate
i'm like hey for the fighters i have on
i want to give them a shoe that
represents them and they're like say
less like what do you want to do for
sugar so i came up with this idea i'm
like can you find can you source this
shoe like we'll find it so shout out to
uh suplex sneakers they're in philly but
as far as any hard shoe to get any shoe
in general they're the best in the world
my boy mike monster down there is a pet
fox whatever so these are the shoes i
selected for you they're the jordan one
jay balvins they're the most
yes they're the most
unique jordan ones like so the jordan
one silhouette has been done a million
times they do all these collabs
and these are the most unique and loud
ones and to me these represent you
because you got to be the most unique
guy in the ufc so these jordan ones
represent you my man dude i'm [ __ ]
problem
i feel like they're right up your alley
man and takashi 69 is gonna be all over
these
bro they're [ __ ] fired
i don't i only have myself but they're
[ __ ] dude these are the sickest
[ __ ] shoes i've ever seen i love that
pink
i mean
is that not a sugar issue sick issue of
ever yes they're so simple not easy to
get they kind of appreciate them no
problem yeah thanks for doing the show
man so dope
yeah aren't they dope
oh yeah these are [ __ ] friends i'm a
fan of jay balvin too yeah they got the
smiley face in them dude
they got all the crazy colors they're
the most unique jordan of all time dude
yeah those are nuts but those are from
me and my friends at suplex and philly
dude yes thank you guys hopefully you
rock them of course guys you're careful
rocking these bad boys you don't want to
step on these yeah you don't get robbed
either hollywood's getting a little
dicey man oh dude the difference
yeah dude those are you in a nutshell
brother i appreciate it yeah you got it
brother super sick
dude
those represent you dog so hopefully you
wear them oh don't be the guy just put
some on the shelf or something okay i'm
already i'm already thinking of ideas
with that you're gonna get dope it's my
suitcase that i'm already thinking these
will go with yes sir i think i'm gonna
get a sick ticket though
man they're the ones that source those
and found dude shout out suplex they're
here in l.a uh they're in philly philly
but they're you know they're worldwide
you'll see them on uh
dude yeah man so i can't thank you
enough yeah i always support you you
crush this as usual you're the first
guest since i left show time to be on
food truck diary i hit you up my dude
yeah my team's running on this on think
boy now i need a big guess you said say
less yes and a fight companion
calabasas
that dude thank you so much yeah i
really appreciate that that was [ __ ]
no heel up tell your boy takashi 69
what's up
hopefully enjoyed the food and uh yeah
man appreciate you do it yeah thank you
everybody thanks for doing it brother
dude these are [ __ ]
[Music]
i need everything i get super thick boy